[Applause]
to steal that one oh yeah
this doesn't end all right
put your clothes back on happy Friday
everybody as you know it's Friday so
that means we welcome the guests first
so let's do that after every podcast she
dumps Gatorade on her guests host of the
sidelines sanity podcast Michelle Tafoya
he has the body of a model buried in his
basement comedian Jim Florentine
like a hedgehog she's prickly but
lovable and eats worms boxes contributor
cat tip
and finally Bigfoot report sightings of
him my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion tyrant
now before we get to some news stories
it's Friday so we're gonna do this
Greg's leftovers hmm
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
and when they suck I die a little every
time
so here we go a new study shows divorced
or single senior citizens are more
likely to develop memory loss as opposed
to married women who never forget
anything
ah yeah old-timey humor
that's old-timey humor
damn wife a transgender cyclist won
first place in a woman's event this week
she claimed the Wind made her feel just
like Lance Armstrong except she has two
testicles
all right Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
has stepped down after a 41-year career
with the company at his retirement party
he was given an engraved mug with his
name spelled wrong
[Laughter]
former president Donald Trump is facing
the threat of arrest for allegedly
paying hush money to porn star Stormy
Daniels his lawyers say it's not the
first time she's ignored a gag order
[Music]
I don't get it
anyway a new study shows aircraft noise
can cause heart damage especially if
what you hear is welcome to Spirit Air
so mean video has surfaced of Anthony
fauci going door to door in a DC
neighborhood to talk people into getting
the vaccine
he was also selling those little cookies
he makes in his tree
[Applause]
Keith olberman was spotted outside Trump
Tower this week I was in the area so out
of respect I let him squeegee my
windshield
he really is he's a homeless weirdo now
Almighty that he's fallen is that the
phrase who cares schools in L.A closed
this week due to a teacher's strike and
until teachers return to work this
leaves thousands of students with no one
to have sex with
it's true
Al Franken hosted The Daily Show this
week There's no joke here we just really
hoping
we hope he gets back on his feet soon
California saw more torrential rain this
week to stay afloat hundreds of
angelinos were forced to latch
themselves to a Kardashian's ass
according to a new survey dog owners say
36 percent of their conversations are
about their pets
yeah we know said my entire staff
talk about that too all right an
international team of scientists have
created the first full map of a fly's
brain but they say the most difficult
part of the procedure was folding the
map
yeah I actually really like that joke
it's a really small map
finally Columbia University
and I'm not drunk Colombia this is what
happens when I drink coffee before
anyway Columbia University released a
video promoting Hillary Clinton's new
foreign policy class students say
they're excited to take the course but
are concern she'll keep deleting their
emails
foreign
before we get to some stories let's
quickly check in to see what's going on
in Florida
station of counties waves in opposition
Pamela Birch Ford to Florida State
Conference of NAACP branches waves in
opposition Anita dick
[Laughter]
waves in opposition Holden hiscock he's
also an opponent
waves in opposition
God I'm a sucker for that stuff
it's like a pretty normal meeting to me
so let's move on
the TSA gets trippy when it comes to
bringing Skippy yep it's an effort to
ban your precious jar of Peter Pan this
week the TSA tweeted that peanut butter
is in fact a liquid and subject to the
same security rules as all liquids
so in other words pack up everyone the
terrorists have won
they cite the scientific definition of
what a liquid actually is something that
has no definite shape and takes the
Contours dictated by its container
it's no wonder this lady now is to take
the train
but hey when it comes to science I defer
to the guy who grabs my junk for a
living
is that peanut butter is a liquid
perhaps it's just a slow one the brine
kill meat of liquids if you will
thought it was a butter because it's
called peanut butter it's not called
peanut juice or peanut water
therefore the TSA is wrong but can you
blame them it's an agency under the
watchful eye of this guy
a dude who literally looks like a peanut
technically with this definition
everything on Earth is a fluid our cells
are fluid and and by the way who travels
with peanut butter well apparently aside
from Jim Norton but go ahead I think it
was a priest or someone who tweeted that
they got stopped for their thing of
peanut butter so you're thinking okay
why are you bringing that much peanut
butter on a plane okay so now toothpaste
is also considered one of those things
you have to put in the plastic bag right
that's a paste so I could see peanut
butter being sort of the same as a paste
look there need to be procedures I get
all that here's the Practical thing if
I'm Peter Pan or Skippy or Jiff right
now I am marketing travel size packages
of peanut butter that you can put in
those Ziplocs same size 3.4 ounces put
them in the travel aisle put them next
to the peanut butter I don't know that's
what they want you to do and then
they've won right and then they've
really won you know mashed potatoes are
kind of similar to peanut butter that's
what I'm saying I mean really you're
talking about something that is neither
a liquid or a solid like you said
perhaps a paste a paste a paste I saw
this happen though when the year was
2016.
there was this woman wearing Lululemon
leggings who absolutely tore into her
husband for putting the almond butter in
the carry-on instead of checking it
really yeah she yelled at him she called
it unbelievable oh my gosh I will never
forget it because they took it but like
this is how the government works right
because she was mad at her husband when
really she should be mad that there's no
legitimate reason why you can't bring
almond butter on the plane or the fact
that the TSA costs us billions of
dollars a year and multiple studies show
that they miss up to 90 percent of the
you know mock explosives and weapons
that they try to get through in Trials
but that's how the government works it
gets us to all yell at each other and
there's a distraction from all the
abuses of power and tyranny going on and
that's what allows it to continue There
you go so true so true all good yeah you
know
I also wonder if they're still married
yeah they probably are
almond butter on flights but then I
always leave it in the bathroom
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's a great moisturizer Jim how you
doing good I look I actually agree with
the TSA because really like if you think
about if a man could be a woman why
can't peanut butter be a liquid
but seriously who was bringing peanut
butter on a plane I gotta using that for
a snack yes am I gonna whip it out giant
celery stick God's got it he's got a
dress
right I've never sat next to a guy who
goes hey man you got any crackers
no and that and if someone some guys
bring on a like a vacation you think his
wife's gonna be happy he's like hey
let's go to a local restaurant he's like
I got the peanut butter
I bought the paint what are we going out
for we got look how much money we save
maybe they'll let us let us in a table
I eat this and you know at some point
someone's gonna put like a vest around
around the jar I'd say it's their
emotional support
oh that's good that's good I wonder
though Tyrus do you think that maybe
there wasn't they were aware of a threat
involving peanut butter yeah oh my God
the plane's going down someone smeared
peanut butter in a pilot's eyes oh no
it's everywhere it's on the windows it's
wait oh we can never mind we're good
problems averted
the whole point here's the deal human
beings are what 80 water so I guess none
of us should get through exactly this is
stupid no water bottle
then I just walk through and buy a water
bottle so again what is the point of
this yeah looking for peanut butter like
I used to get when I brought protein
powder with me I was like they're like
oh this is a powder you can't bring it
through I said well I don't have any
Waters I can't mix it and then put it on
the plane and once we get an elevated it
explodes and everybody loses weight
focus on keeping us safe I heard too
that they that people who like to
smuggle pot will stick it into the
peanut butter and smuggle it oh that's a
great idea
I'm sorry I'm sorry I've heard that or
to put it in their ass
the drug dogs are gonna love that how
can you put it on I mean they'll be all
over put a jar of peanut butter in your
ass
I mean I'm willing to try but
like you like you haven't already
oh my gosh we're all dumber now yeah
yeah yes I'm so glad we did this topic I
learned a lot you smeared us all yes yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else